doch genau eine woche bis zur
fußball-weltmeisterschaft in russland
das heißt noch 37 tage bis zur deutschen
titelverteidigung
man könnte auch sagen löw ist in dr
meine damen und herren ja und das land
kennt nur noch ein thema fußball
der stammbaum die kanzlerin da
vielleicht ist das für sie interessant
nein gar nicht
aber ich finde auch auf diese wm soll
man sich durchaus freuen
für die russischen fans für unsere für
den sport das ganze boykott gerät ist
quatsch wenn überhaupt kann man auf die
fifa sauber sein
sie wissen da gab es damals diesen
korruptionsverdacht bei der vergabe an
russland aber das ist ja nie wirklich
bewiesen worden
vorher in russland ermittlungen
fehlanzeige
in putins reich erklären sie die für die
wm-bewerbung relevanten computer waren
geleast und sind jetzt zerstört keine
daten mehr vorhanden
das passiert wie oft habe ich aus
versehen meinem computer kaputt
geschlagen jetzt mal ernsthaft dass
deutschland seine wm gekauft hat fangen
noch völlig in ordnung
aber danach hätte man das stoppen müssen
oder gibt's doch nicht
russland wird die teuerste
weltmeisterschaft aller zeiten mit putin
befreundete oligarchen haben die stadien
gebaut und ohne ende über dunkle kanäle
zusätzliche kohle abkassiert es blöd für
die russische restbevölkerung viele
russen leben in bitterer armut
das riesige land steckt in einer
rezession
viele der größten firmen wie gazprom
oder der ölkonzern rosneft werden vom
staat kontrolliert genug die roten berg
putins ehemalige judo trainingspartner
seine bauunternehmen bekommen staatliche
milliarden aufträge
vielen dank für ihre eröffnete bin ja
dafür nicht lang allein das stadion in
sankt petersburg ist dank oligarchen
jetzt zehnmal so teuer wie geplant zehn
mal so teuer in deutschland undenkbar
und damit sich da ein russischer keiner
drüber aufregt hat putin schon im
letzten jahr auf sicher das
demonstrationsrecht für die spielorte
der wm eingeschränkt stark eingeschränkt
wichtig ist nur finde ich dass man
solche missstände bei putin offen und
kritisch anspricht sowie der fifa
präsident gianni infantino
ihre themen wir sind ein team und wir
werden das großartigste event in der
geschichte des fußballs organisieren
ich fühle mich hier zu hause dann zieh
doch da hindu schleimer
putin sonnt sich im glanz der wm im
gegenzug drückt die fifa beide augen zu
beim thema staatsdoping ja das ist ein
thema das muss man zugeben dass das
russische wm-team von 2014 stand unter
schwerem dopingverdacht und jetzt
zufällig ganz kurz vor der wm werden die
ermittlungen eingestellt
immerhin darf der ard journalist hajo
seppelt er den doping skandal aufgedeckt
hat jetzt doch zur wm reisen
allerdings muss er noch zu einer
befragung also einreise wird klappen
ausreise mal gucken
trotz allem finde ich muss aber die
vorfreude auf die wm langsamer in gang
kommen es gibt es doch gar nicht oder
deutschland ist schließlich favorit oder
war das österreich ist ja auch egal
ich freue mich jetzt schon unseren wm
song ralph siegel hat dschinghis khan
exhumiert
[Musik]
wir spielen alle an die wand hahahahaha
an der stelle macht der lacher sogar mal
sind langsam schlägt die
kommerzialisierung des fußballs ein
wenig auf die laune aber wie fifa hat
jetzt endlich reagiert und ein stimmungs
beauftragten angeheuert hier ist
sebastian die party kann ohne buff
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herreweghe was jetzt sehen sie denn hier
die wm stimmung ist doch bombe und diese
leute hier nehmen die nächsten fünf
wochen nur noch fußball
die werden nicht mehr zur arbeit gehen
sich gehen lassen ganztags grillen bier
saufen die eigenen kinder vernachlässigt
und kein geschlechtsverkehr mehr haben
keiner geht mehr teil der separat an
[Applaus]
da wirklich jetzt denke ich macht
jenseits von groß fragen der fan kann
einem doch nur noch leid tun die
ticketpreise haben noch mal angezogen in
der gruppenphase kostet die günstigste
karte 105 dollar
das finale mindestens 450 plus
reisekosten harper dafür sind die spiele
doch immer schlechter geworden und das
gleicht sich aus
nein wege da können sie noch so rom
zehntausende deutsche fans werden sich
auf den weg nach russland machen um
endlich moskau zu erleben was opa er nur
fast geschafft hat wir von der fifa wir
brauchen die fans nicht vom menschlichen
her nein aber als kulisse im stadion als
biomasse die in der pause überteuertes
bier kauft übrigens und das ist unser
fifa geschenk an die fans in russischen
stadien gibt es bier mit alkohol was
sagt man dazu
ja das ist schön
[Applaus]
wer war der mann der typ aus der nivea
werbung ist nicht wichtig
endlich wird wieder zusammengebracht was
zusammengehört saufen und fans wenn man
ehrlich zu einer echten wm gehören
solche szenen hier
[Musik]
übrigens der rutschte die in super das
finde ich aber jetzt merke ich glaube
ihre fifa muss langsam echt aufpassen
ihr habt überdreht mit dem kommerz bei
der wm 2026 das ist leider kein witz
spielen in der gruppenphase 48 teams das
ist doch irrsinn ist ein problem da
haben sie recht es gibt 193 staaten auf
der welt und nur 48 dürfen mitreden ja
warum nicht alle
warum nicht mal paarung wie
tadschikistan gegen amrum ja galapagos
gegen nummer land neue märkte natürlich
spielen dann auch mannschaft mit den ich
richtig gut sind in
wie heißt das fußball genau aber
irgendwas ist ja immer neuer präsident
der infantino überlegt sogar in der
gruppenphase das unentschieden
abzuschaffen jedes mal elf meter
schießen damit telegener wird das hatte
mit fußball nichts mehr zu tun dass die
münze werfen einander wir müssen hier
progressiv denken es muss mehr spannung
rein
ich habe neulich zum infantino gesagt ja
nie idee wenn eine mannschaft so gut ist
deutschland zum beispiel da sagt man ok
ab jetzt muss jogi löw mindestens zwei
frauen aufstellen und entdecken und der
dicke darf nicht so sein
nun mal quer gedacht ja oder wenn es
nach 120 minuten immer noch eins zu eins
steht warum nicht einfach mal den löwen
reinlassen und gucken was passiert damit
rechnen die doch nicht es ist doch nur
noch kommerz gut ehrlicherweise muss
sagen ich moderiere diese wm jetzt auch
nicht ehrenamt ist kann aber ich muss
das zum beispiel ganz normal versteuern
die fahrzeit auf ihre wm gewinn in
brasilien waren es 1,6 milliarden gar
keine steuer natürlich nicht wir sind
doch ein gemeinnütziger verein brot für
die welt ja auch ein sportler denen sie
reden mir die wm stimmung nicht ab und
in musik die höhe
so sieht
[Musik]
wir sind total krumm haben uns noch nie
gejuckt
wir können uns nach
sie war
gianni infantino keine ein gewinnst du
seit lokal
[Applaus]
passend hochwasser kommen weil ich auch
so
[Musik]
postbank papiere fest